james said something on twitter a few
weeks ago and i wanted to find out if it
was true he said that you were
he said that vigilante was recast and
you got the role is that true and if it
is what was it like coming into a show
where the cast had already started
going to work
uh it was it is true yeah i was um i
came in a little later to the project it
could be a little intimidating because
everyone had been working together and i
was kind of a new kid on set but
everyone was so lovely like this is just
the best group of people um and everyone
was uh very very kind and sweet and i
straight away from day one i didn't feel
any of that pressure which was which was
really really great it helps when you've
got james and john at the top and um it
just you know it sets sets the standard
my first day of shooting was scenes with
john and we were just having back and
forth and uh john is such a good actor
and improviser that straight away we
didn't that we didn't it didn't need too
much we would just we just bounced off
each other which is great goth what's
your favorite color dude it's it's yes
or no questions i just said it right
okay yeah uh guff is your favorite color
teal bro what the
what
i'm gonna go through all the colors and
then eventually we'll find out which one
he likes best james has sort of
described vigilante as a sociopath
especially when compared to
peacemaker how would you describe him
though i mean sociopath is is pretty
accurate um i think it's what's what's
nice what he lends to to chris's story
is that you know he's he's trying to
figure out um where he is on the moral
spectrum and then you see that's his
that's what he's trying to figure out
throughout the show and then
vigilante represents what he what he was
like before um maybe not quite as
psychotic but you know they're
definitely you know killing people for
graffitiing or whatever you know it you
know so it's uh he's definitely a
psychopath um but with with that comes a
lot of color colors and a lot of um
uh
a lot of different ways to try and
figure out what it is he's thinking
yeah he does have a lot of heart
and he says he doesn't have like regular
emotions but he's very attached to
to peacemaker and feels betrayed that he
he like
had to get tortured yeah it's that thing
of you know he's he the one thing that i
could i i knew i could play at any point
is how much he loves peacemaker and how
much he loves their relationship as and
being a superhero um to him that's so
important so then of course when he has
an episode three he gets tortured and
peacemakers just like doesn't really
care
he's he starts struggling with him a
little bit uh just figure out how he
could let that happen but
um yeah that was very fun but then i
realized you were you were just
supporting me and helping me to become
the best me that i could be someone who
doesn't spill the beans while being
electrocuted and having half his toe cut
off you seem to be walking okay well
i'll probably never walk as good again
but it's worth it you know for being a
more evolved human being so
thank you he's like if napoleon dynamite
were a superhero
yeah that's that's a pretty accurate
yeah that's not bad only dynamite is a
superhero episode four was when we
really got to know him a little bit more
i mean in particular in that very end
you know the the walk down the hallway
in the jail cell we don't really know
is he full of it is he gonna go get his
ass kicked how did you play that what
was kind of going through your mind when
you when you on the day when you when
you shot that it was uh i mean when i
read it firstly like j i mean james just
wrote as soon as i read it i was like
wow he he just wrote this incredible
sequence um and
it was uh
not the easiest to walk down the hallway
because you know it's all in slow-mo and
you can't hear anything but on the day
it's in in real speed you've got like 50
uh
background actors who are just
shouting in your face and just all down
you have to do everything you can to try
and block it out and look relaxed and
it's a very fun scene to
to play because you know as an audience
member you're thinking is this guy gonna
um is he a lamb to the slaughter which
it kind of looks like or you know or you
know what's going on why isn't he
intimidated he looks very relaxed
which then pays off so well for them
when the moment happens what was it like
shooting that fight scene with the white
supremacists because to watch that was
very gratifying and i'm sure you've
heard that before yeah it was i mean it
was a lot of fun it was um it's
obviously there's another time you don't
hear that the actors were very lovely
yeah and the stunt guys um so uh and and
they were they were fantastic stunt men
as well they made me feel very
comfortable with trying to figure out
what we were doing and and making sure
because i'm always my my thing is i'm
always terrified that i'm you know i
have to make it look like i'm gonna
broke shop song but accident
accidentally then do it do it it's funny
because then these guys are huge you
know and he was like you know like
actually just hit me on the chest and i
was like okay he's like you can go ten
times harder so like i went like much
harder he was like that's like you can
go wait i was like okay like it's funny
because i'm like oh no i might hurt him
he's like i don't i think even if i
tried if i had a sledgehammer i don't
think i could hurt him but it's uh it's
a funny uh it's a funny place to be
because you still you want to sell it
but you also want to make sure you're
you're
doing the right thing yeah being safe
what was your reaction when you found
out that vigilante's
ringtone
was uh aqua's
barbie girl
who is this lovely girl yeah it's so
good because you just you can never put
your finger on him and you just don't
know what this character is so then he
just
returns bob you go you're like okay that
uh that's amazing that's another i what
why what
so he had kind of a rocky start to join
the squad everybody sort of thinks that
he's just
a crazy person but by the end of episode
seven it seems like he's fully a member
of the team in fact we see the team gel
together over the course of you know
four five six and seven um
how how does does he feel like he's
being accepted by the team at this point
yeah he definitely i think there's those
the moments where they've had the good
time to send a photo you know them all
having a good time and he starts to feel
like he i think
that's the scene with uh harcourt where
uh i think he asks if it's like if they
can
get into a chihuahua and he's like
attempting a joke but it just doesn't
land but at least he's like he he
definitely feels like he's part of the
team at that point and you know he feels
like it's okay to not have his mask on
for the first few episodes he doesn't
want to ever
reveal his identity so yeah he
definitely feels like he's a part of the
team at this stage we guess this means
butterflies can use any life form as a
host chihuahua
probably wouldn't fit would be cool
though that wouldn't be cool at all why
would that be cool you tell me
it wouldn't be there's your answer
how do you think he's changed from the
beat from the first time we saw him
in episode one to episode seven i think
adrian has been you know he kind of it's
his main thing is his relationship with
with chris um with peacemaker and uh
he gets more comfortable with the group
and the rest of it but he's still kind
of
an odd psychotic uh
guy
he hasn't changed too much he's he's
maybe
um gotten a little closer to peacemaker
which makes him happy what's been your
favorite scene out of the first seven to
shoot so far and pretty much any scene
with john like we we have we just got to
have a lot of back and forth a lot of
comedy and i you know i was definitely
uh breaking character a lot just because
it would be too funny to hold back to
hold on to james had said on twitter
that you kept your american accent all
the way through filming and then john
had no idea until you guys rapped that
yeah
what was his reaction do you remember
what it was i i wasn't i wasn't there
for it james i think james told me
afterwards that he told him he was like
what he's english what um so i uh yeah
no i kind of for me it's it's i found it
easier to just stay in the accent while
shooting and even going home and my wife
suggested it to me uh a few years ago
and now she's like okay maybe maybe you
could just give a little break if i can
see my husband for
once in in five months um but yeah it's
something it's helpful but yeah i i stay
american the whole time she's like i get
it de niro
yeah like you all get it yeah um
going back to
how you got cast another thing did the
james said was that he reached out to
elizabeth banks to find out if you were
a nice guy and like what your deal was
because she worked with you on pitch
perfect do you do you
it's been 10 years since picture perfect
came out i'm luke station manager you
must be becky the intern um it's uh hey
man what's up i'm jesse
i'm luke you're late
yeah it's that's a long time yeah yeah
do you have any recollection of of of
shooting that and what that role meant
to you i mean it was it was great fun it
was a very quick shoot i i just you know
i went down we went down to uh baton
rouge i think i think it was lsu that
where we shot that and i was only there
for like a week at the beginning of the
shoot and uh elizabeth banks was awesome
and a lot of fun to work with and
um
it's funny because ten years i met maybe
i wasn't an [ __ ] then but could have
been now 10 years that's a long time but
james james likes to check in before
before you know he likes he likes what
someone's doing he's just then he just
wants to do his double check and and you
know
we'd all you know we'd work together so
it was
kind of like
got past got past the [ __ ] test
congratulations very last question
before i let you go can you give me
any sort of uh deep tease to season
the season finale what can you tell me
about the season finale without giving
too much away it's
it's just epic i got to watch it uh a
few days ago um it's
the the audience is going to love it i i
was i was
thinking you know all the episodes are
great there's no difference but when we
watch seven and eight back to back and
i'm telling you people are gonna
absolutely love it it's it's huge it's
gonna be yeah it's it's everything comes
together whether it's comedy drama it's
the story
action it just all comes to a melting
point
[Music]